ladies and gentlemen welcome back I am
joined by Robin Swan and Anthony summers
you may recognize them from the most
recent Netflix series on the
disappearance of Madeleine McCann guys
welcome to the show thank you very much
so you are investigative journalists but
you're also married and you've been
working together for about 30 years is
that right that's I think what my wife
would say works right never I've never
really been fond of that description
investigative journalist but when asked
and I suppose I would sit and as to nail
it down on my bank manager Andrew driver
or an investigative journalist I would
go for the third but I always think that
it's a misnomer in the sense that
everyone in this business in the
journalist business should in theory try
to dig beyond the grass that you can see
and find out what's underneath and yet
that is what we do that that's what
we've done in our career together yes so
having a look at your back catalog of
books 9/11 Pearl Harbor Richard Nixon
and Madeleine McCann there's some high
pressure topics in there do you ever
find the difficulty and the emotion and
the pressure of writing with quite
inflammatory topics ever the lines kinda
get crossed with the relationship at all
does that ever kind of come in or are
you able to kind of mediate those pretty
effectively as a thoroughly code husband
and co-author I relief Robin to us on a
serious note always the one to direct
the serious note here you know frankly
we're we're incredibly lucky to be able
to do the kind of work we do you know
what a privilege to be able to explore
you know
some of the most important cultural and
historical moments of the last century
and try to bring your own little bit of
extra information into that to try to
write that story well sure there's
there's pressure and we don't always
agree but I think the reason we have
found that we're able to work together
well is that we have sometimes we have
slightly different strengths but we're
both incredibly relentless when it comes
to the digging and and you know the we
really are you know if one isn't pushing
the other one is and I think so so we
have a real simpatico in that way but
also I think each of us respects the
others the others talent you know tony
has an extraordinary ability to make the
complex simple you know to drive what we
call a coach and horses through a a
knotty problem and make it possible for
readers to understand something in a
really you know basic but interesting
way and I think you know I'm pretty good
at it you know getting the big picture
of things and and you know delivering
you know to the to the project all the
nuts and bolts so that we can do that so
that we can have that material and to
base the story on you know I think
Robin's been talking brother or so she
said we don't we don't really cash on
things well quite often we say no that's
not right
no it's not right because look this is
what I was digging up all this is of the
X hundred interviews we've done on a
subject and do you remember that
so-and-so said this show we have to
think about that and what the important
thing is that that we're playing mental
ping-pong and it's it's a terrific asset
actually I have a friend and sometime
colleague in the United States who
already done one book about that
seemingly eternal story the
assassination of President Kennedy in
1963 and having done one book which
success I'm quite a serious book not
just one of those books one more of
those books about the Kennedy
assassination he launched intuitively
search for a second he's been on that
now by my most recent count for about
twenty five years possibly more on his
own and I think that's fatal for him
I've got a feeling he's going to died
without the book having been published
but what he lacks is what we we do have
which is someone to pay play
intellectual ping-pong with to say what
I've just written these couple of
paragraphs what do you think about that
is that fair isn't that fair all he all
he can do is rattle around in its own
head and it's a huge advantage to have
two people who are sort of on the same
wavelength about things working together
I suppose as well when we're talking
about these inflammatory topics that are
highly charged it's the sort of thing
that requires quadruple checking and you
don't want to be making any errors
absolutely
you bet and then of course at the end of
each book trail you then have the not
only the editor and the art of editing
in publishing is except in some
circumstances is not what once it was
when I came into the business in the
beginning and thought then and this is a
real discipline to not least in this
case which has seen a lot of lawsuits
you then have that lawyer and a good
lawyer will make sure that you're not
making huge gratuitous a Roger and
getting yourself into great libel suit
on the other hand a good lawyer will be
one who does not just crush what you're
trying to say and one has to be very
careful at that but I also think it and
and perhaps more important than what any
what we think or what any way or thinks
or anything like that is we are trying
to get to the historical truth here you
know in our 911 book we were writing at
the time that all of the 911
movement was was at its height and there
were stories circulating about World
Trade Center seven and you know what hit
the Pentagon etc etc etc that just had
no basis in fact and these are people's
lives their loved ones were talking
about you know did a missile was it not
really a plane that hit the Pentagon
wasn't it a missile well what happened
to the two all the victims who are on
that plane are you not thinking of their
family have you no compassion when you
come forward as a wild conspiracy theory
about what really happened there have
you not as I have done looked at the
exhibits in the new salary case which
Mesaba Zacharias masala another of the
suspects in the in the 9/11 attacks the
exhibits in that case show very clearly
some horribly graphic images of the
victims of the plane attack on the
Pentagon you know this kind of you know
conspiracy theory fake news it's been
around a long time and you know it's a
hard job as historians or journalists or
whatever you want to call us to try to
get beyond that to the actual truth of
the event because there has to be some
reality there you know you have you are
entitled to your own opinion but you are
not entitled to your own facts
and that remains true is always true and
it will be ever thus you know these days
we talk about the trolls the internet
trolls I we didn't have the word
troubles although it existed in stories
about magic so it we didn't use the word
trolls in journalism we had the cranks
and you know you were getting a letter
from a cracker when I did my first book
I got thousands of letters letters those
those old-fashioned things yep and
through the post with a stamp on them
yes and and I would know immediately the
nature of the person writing to me
because they would either have
bright red ink Oh greedy come to cut on
the address in writing the address
probably in capital letters and written
sometimes very carefully and you knew
that inside there would be a
communication from a crack possibly with
with an idea suggestion about the story
mm-hmm not usually but rubric it's not
usually full of venom now there's a
totally different phenomenon which
you've seen unsure and regularly which
is the stuff that comes in over the
internet which is often from people who
really should be locked up well the
problem is it's so easy for people to
just the distance from brain to
fingertips or brain to mouth has been
reduced so far and with the ease of
access and you know if you guys have
Twitter or Instagram or a Facebook page
or whatever it is it takes them on two
seconds they browse on a mobile ah and
they can they can delegate to their
opinion out to the masses as it were
even when a lot of the time it's
probably not worthy of that so I want to
get on without without consulting their
conscience without consulting their own
humanity they forget that there's a
person on the other end of this and you
know as you touched on there Robin
people forget and this is a key point I
want to discuss with regards to the
Madeleine McCann case that people do
forget it's it's not just a story and
the same thing goes for this you guys
aren't fiction writers and they're not
complaining at you because you've ended
the story in a way that they didn't like
it's that you're reporting the facts in
as virtuously away as you guys can and
if they don't like the way that the
facts come across presuming that you've
done it with to the best of your
professional abilities they're really
just arguing with reality their problem
is I don't like what reality is serving
me I need someone to vent at and it
happens to be that your name is on the
front cover of the pot for a cover of
the book or in the credits of the TV
show so moving on to
the Madeleine McCann case the first
thing upon watching the most recent
Netflix series and I'm sure lots of
people who are listening will have seen
it as well the first thing that struck
me was how I don't to say bungled but
how oddly the case was dealt with upon
immediate investigation in terms of the
crime scene in terms of everything else
that was that was probably the most one
of the most shocking things I got out of
it when you you mentioned the crime
scene and I guess you're thinking about
the accounts which I obviously also
although we were interviewed for the
series we weren't part of it in the
Netflix series though we are in each
episode so we have worked it closely and
we found that virtually everything and I
mean 99.9% was accurate so far as we
know and we I think ourselves and in the
show's discuss what happened in the
crime scene woman woman goes into
apartment apparently finds child missing
goes out makes a terrible cry all their
considerably large party no no ten
people the other doctors and their
friends come come rushing to the
apartment they're all they're all
trampling around the apartment and and
then they called the police a call when
the police eventually arrive they come
in they trample around the apartment at
some point dogs come into the search
dogs come into the apartment and that is
completely contrary to what the police
like the way the police like a crime
scene to be handled in what they called
the golden hour the first hour that is
why when one sees for instance a
shooting in the street you see on the
news nightly scenes in which the police
have put up tapes and stop people
stopped the people trampling over the
golden evidence the first evidence the
evidence was there
and that wasn't done in this case but
you talked about the possible thundering
and so on
well that was daunting at some stage in
the investigation but it does if there's
also a thing called human nature when
the police were called to the apartment
they thought there was a little girl who
was missing and she wandered off what
had happened where was she maybe she's
going to turn out in turn up in D in the
wardrobe and under the bed maybe she's
there really maybe she's just hiding
from mommy and daddy and of course the
none of that food proved to be the case
but during that time people had not were
not thinking of the crime of possible
crime they they weren't thinking of
something sinister that wouldn't be
solved for more than a decade they were
just trying to find that little girl who
might be here so there was a reason and
and a sort of a justification for why
the golden r was ignored I suppose it's
a short-term pain for a long-term gain
that you need to make a judgement on
upon the beginning of the case right
there you need to they want to think oh
well if she is in here somewhere or if
it's not a crime we need to work more
expeditiously rather than delicately but
obviously the benefit of hindsight is is
fantastic and looking back you say well
why didn't they just close the earther
okay so I think I think what you say is
true but absolutely it was a resource
and division of labour issue as well but
the first Portuguese police office to
arrive on the scene or the sort of local
beat cops who you know would not
necessarily have been all that clued in
to the idea of crime scene preservation
etc whereas immediately an hour later
when the more senior detectives arrived
they were themselves horrified by this
you know tarnishing of the of the
evidence by having all these people
trample it you know they were none too
pleased with their colleagues that this
had happened and I think that was then
compounded the Portuguese police's
initial
mistakes in terms of the crime scene or
then compounded by two other things one
they fail to clear the parents of
involvement
you know usually in cases like this it
is always a family member who you look
at first and in in the words of the the
policeman who was responsible for
reviewing this case and deciding you
know it wasn't handled very well he
thought that they had failed to clear
the clear the ground in front of them
and that's that's an important mistake
that should have been addressed very
early on instead it festered and the
second thing was the involvement of the
british police you know you had a crime
taking a crime or an abduction or a
missing child taking place in portugal
but she's a british child
so therefore the parents who don't speak
the language are immediately reaching
out for all the support they can get and
that's coming back at them in terms of
multiple police agencies all wanting to
help all wanting to get their Pacha no
we all wanted to be the hero and that
also didn't play well it felt to the
portuguese like the Brits were trampling
all over them and being a colonial power
and being arrogant and and the
Portuguese themselves became very
suspicious what are all these you know
British police officers doing and we're
having for actually having their their
British police colleagues followed so so
the bad relationship again didn't help
in any attempt to find Matt on so the
British thought that the Portuguese were
living in the Stone Age in the sense
that they weren't computerised in the
wake of people from when Scotland Yard
we eventually became a vote or just the
police that was sent out on the 8th on
the 1st from England they saw all the
you know cards in boxes and and it's a
tent temporary headquarters with a lot
of paperwork and so on and people and
guys typing with two fingers on on on
old typewriters that's that's not how it
happens that pretty headquarters in
England anymore and so
there grew a feeling that the Portuguese
felt as though they would be being at a
certain level thought they were being
treated as though they were from the
third world they're not presented yeah
they're not presented fantastically well
I suppose and there definitely does seem
to be a lot of friction that you can
tell between themselves and everyone
else and you've got the chief I think it
was the chief of Portuguese police being
the times he was going for lunch and
coming back were being noted down in the
newspaper and the British newspapers
were being quite quite a accuser tree
and and stuff like that so that that
takes us onto the the press coverage and
a question that I really wanted to ask
you was why do you think this particular
case captured such international
attention both at the time and then what
why is it still doing it now was it
right place right time was it the did it
have the right look look I the real
reason the initial reason that there was
huge press coverage was because the
McCanns
quite wisely they thought wanted it in
the end it became the bane of their
existence but that night when they were
sitting in their agony after the police
had come and the police had had gone for
the time being three four o'clock in the
morning they sat with their friends in
apartment five a with the little girl
missing what can we do that
the police how the police doing enough
know maybe they could took a long time
to come maybe they're not and maybe so
we should do something they tried to
reach out to TV stations through
relatives in the UK on on the telephone
and by eight hundred nine o'clock in the
morning the news was it was very brief
but the news was being broadcast on Sky
News and and other stations in the UK
whereas that at the time it wasn't on
Portuguese news and I gather at all and
during the case it is there's a
Portuguese law which says that
information cannot be given out
beginner bylaw while it's ongoing
now that's very different from the
reality which later on involved you know
people saying things on the Qt saying on
the quiet saying to journalists we can't
we're not telling you this really but
happens everywhere it's an old-fashioned
police tactic but but it you did got
medleys but anyway become food from the
McCanns own effort the press first knew
about it but what the McCanns by their
own admission also thought was wait a
minute this is the age of the Internet
Gerry McCann that the father had a
sister I believe called Philomena in in
the north of Scotland who was hip to
computers and who had students and she
bought students or former students into
garage a sort of makeshift shed where
they said I'm within what 24 36 hours
people in New Zealand knew about this
case people who would never otherwise
have known about it which had the effect
of getting Madeline's picture the
picture that it'll go out there to
millions whereas in a similar case in
the past that it would not have gone out
to millions or certainly not for a very
long time and in the end though starting
an avalanche of chatter on the internet
chatter which was often far from
responsible I think you are totally
right that it became a monster of its
own and started to roll along on its own
momentum it's a difficult situation you
know the listeners at home I wonder what
they think they would have done in that
situation would you have allowed the
police to have conducted the
investigation quietly would you have
thought that that was the best route or
would you have tried to react by getting
as much information as much exposure as
possible to have this have the fall of
this little girl out there I
I would guess that the vast majority of
people would just one maximum exposure
as much it feels like you're doing
something right like you you're helpless
in this situation what can I do what can
I actually how can i impact and help you
know you're not an investigator you
don't understand forensics you don't
have these sort of things for one of the
things you can do is disseminate right
but that's that's not only your natural
reaction but it's also the best advice
from from the experts in the field you
know some of your listeners might be too
young to remember it but years ago when
you know the National Center for Missing
and Exploited Children in the u.s. first
got going for instance they were behind
a great campaign we're missing
children's faces were put on those those
cardboard milk cartons and that was a
way of getting maximum exposure because
everybody got a carton of milk yeah that
was a way of getting maximum exposure
for every missing child and it's a
brilliant tool and the Internet is a
wonderful and enormous milk carton in
that sense but so we took I mean it
could it can be incredibly effective and
what we do know is that publicity does
help you know there was a recent case I
believe in Minnesota where young a young
girl was missing for a period of months
and she was spotted by a passerby
because her face was recognized you see
these kind of things in the Elizabeth
Smart case again she was recognized
there was an oddity about the the you
know the scenes she was seen it by a
passerby and was brought to police
attention so the idea that maximum
exposure isn't the right thing is
actually wrong it is the right thing but
it can turn around and bite you back
yeah sorry it could have been precisely
the right thing in the case of little
Madeleine McCann not least because
Madeleine McCann had a thing called
coloboma which is scientific medical
word for a blemish in her right pupil of
her right eye which if you were
if she was walking past you in a store
or loved the pavement you wouldn't
notice immediately but it was a
blemishes it's an obvious thing so in
those first days when she was missing
and even later if you had people's
attention had been drawn to this feature
of her eyes then perhaps she she could
have might have been recognized and the
police or the shop security or wherever
could it could have been called so it
was a it was like the picture on the
milk carton it was a relevant thing to
do
yes I understand why why was this so
much flip-flopping and so many very
inflammatory headlines about this case I
don't know how it works with libelous
press coverage and stuff like that but
upon reading just a cross-section that
you see on the documentary it struck me
just how outlandish some of the
headlines were like Robert Marat being
accused of everything under the Sun the
I think he's a swiss national their
guide was the computer programmer
russian he was being accused of
everything under the Sun
they'd flip-flop from the police being
at fault to the McCanns being at fault
to the dogs - not the dogs - it just
seemed like the most temperamental and
maximally extreme headlines that could
come out about this case at all times is
is that is there an understand
explanation for that it sells papers
that I don't mean that I this case
continues to sell papers it's it's it's
a terrible terrible truth but the real
thing that seemed to be going on during
that summer of 2007 going into the fall
of 2008 is that the the police the
Portuguese police were becoming
frustrated with the way they were being
portrayed in the British press so they
were leaking to their Portuguese press
contacts little bits have been from
that they were developing that was
counter to the narrative of the McCanns
as victims that would get printed in the
Portuguese press and then picked up and
reprinted in the British press with a
few little nuances of their own the
translation issue etc that would then in
turn come back and play again into the
Portuguese press system so they were
reporting on the reporting and and they
were reporting on the leaks and it just
kept building on itself and then you had
a point in the summer where in their
frustration the Portuguese police did
something that they had been offered at
the beginning of the summer which is
they took the British police up on the
offer of using these highly trained
police dogs and from the moment the
police dogs arrived on the scene in
Portugal the entire sort of focus of the
case turned from a missing-child
investigation to a sort of murder
inquiry and once that happened it became
open season on the McCanns there was
there was virtually nothing that
couldn't be printed about them that that
editors wouldn't approve because they
were getting it from multiple quote
unquote sources and and you know it was
you know they felt they had journalistic
and libel cover to do that because there
was such a plethora of reporting coming
out of Portugal that the British media
could pick up on so it just fed itself
it's so bizarre how fact being reported
becomes the next story not the facts
itself and it does I can see how this
kind of ever-growing sphere of crazy
stories starts to become a feedback loop
and feed itself so you touch their upon
the the dog that could have a dog in the
blood dog I think of the two the two
that were brought in the dog handler
himself says these that you can't ask
the dog what it means it's a very kind
of rough-hewn result but it definitely
see
like am i right in saying that they
don't give you it could give you a it's
a hint it could give you a clue to what
might be physical evidence yeah as it
and uh it was quite the contrary
it but in the he told he told me she she
said each that she said it became and
with the police by that time being under
if I in Portuguese terms extraordinary
pressure and feeling pressured they
they've got to do something they've got
to get somewhere
it was a great shining light a moment of
maybe truth yeah the the this is the
dogs have discovered real evidence and
the evidence points to Madeline's blood
in the apartment five a and done this
point to a possible accident and the
ideas well those were accident in which
she might have died and might it be that
that the the McCanns had somehow
accidentally as doctors let done
something to deed to the death of their
own child and then kept her body and
then and the the fable began to just
just grow like Topsy and and and
journalists and reporters who ought to
have known better and editors in London
who should have known much better and
should have said wait a minute what do
we actually knew no ran wild it was a
terrible circus and it took time within
the police investigation for the circus
to be to be corrected and unbroken talk
talk better to that because I think we
should make clear that in the end there
was no DNA evidence that pointed to
anyone at all you know the the
Portuguese police system is it's
different from what we're used to in
lots of places in Western Europe it's a
it's a sort of prosecutorial system in
which the police come up with a
hypothesis about where what they think
the evidence may support whereas we kind
of come out it the other way we have the
evidence and then we
see where the evidence kind of goes so
they're slightly different nuances there
and so the the scenario that Tony was
just describing which to us now having
read all of the evidence actually is a
scenario that is put forward by a senior
investigator in the Portuguese Police
Department in September of 2007 I the
you know that Madeline you know met an
accidental death in the apartment that
her parents hid her body that they
transported it later and that the
McCanns and their friends are all
involved in a pact of silence and in his
words that everyone was lying and in
fact when we traced the the actual
evidence that had come in back before he
came up with this hypothesis you could
see that he was basing it on
mistranslations miss readings of
incomplete reports lack of a complete
lack of evidence not necessarily through
his fault but it was just a compilation
of all of those things so for instance
misinterpretation yeah so of a British
forensic report for instance when the
dogs did their barking and it made their
alerts they went and they did some
scrapings and lifts from various places
and started to do the DNA analysis of
those and what they found was that in
none of the places that they actually
lifted samples from could they identify
any substance as being blood they
identified no DNA as having belonged to
Madeleine McCann and they didn't
identified no DNA as belonging to any
specific member of the McCann family
they did find some DNA of Gerry McCann
on a key fob well they might have done
because he was holding the key fob
because it was for the car he was
driving so there you know there the DNA
evidence was just not there to support
the hypothesis the Portuguese police had
had come to Bank on and in you know we
put this evidence the alleged forensic
evidence to a senior Irish forensic
scientist
and she examined it and she said she was
you know this is a lot of nothing and
that's what we had a whole lot of
nothing is the only evidence which links
the McCann family to the disappearance
of muddling the dogs and the subsequent
DNA fewer that came around that well it
didn't the only evidence because the
great feature of this case and it can't
be said often enough is that wasn't
isn't any evidence no evidence that
we've known about anything we come all
come to learn about it anyway there's no
evidence there is witness testimony lots
of it which is interesting to explore
but basically there is no evidence I
think there that is the only suspicious
it's finding people have question marks
over the McCann the timeline presented
by the McCanns
but the police have concluded that the
timeline discrepancies are the
discrepancies of people telling the
truth about an event they're being asked
to recall you know in a time of stress
and people don't necessarily get things
to the minute correct they were on a
holiday you know they were at a dinner
table they may be off by three minutes
they may be off by five but essentially
people told the same story consistently
enough that they were they were credible
you know I think police officers are
quite often in other investigators if
somebody's story is too perfect that's
more of a worry than you know the nine
people who are all basically telling you
what they remember and everybody's
memories gonna be a little bit different
because she was tying her shoe at the
time or she was worrying about her own
crying baby but essentially they all
told the same story I mean anyone who's
listening who has ever tried to think
back to a situation which occurred even
a day ago under no stress being able to
get your timeline perfectly accurate and
then on top of that people who are
listening as well think about the last
time that there was a even slightly big
secret that was held by more than five
of your friends like it lasted
it's like microseconds before everybody
knows about it the
the thought that the entire party of
nine to ten people were all complicit in
in the disappearance and then covering
it up and then never telling anyone and
no one ever slipping up etc etc it seems
very it seems very unlikely so you
touched on it there there's no evidence
of where Madeleine McCann went is this
almost as if someone's gone in and just
plucked her out of thin air and poof oh
yes entirely I mean she knows it kind of
said it can't be stressed enough so I'm
good to poor English dress it again
there is no evidence it was she just
vanished
to all intents and purposes completely
vanished what has been interesting down
the months has been querying the the
testimony look if if there were three
possibilities how did the little girl
vanish from the plant possibility one
did she as the little girl who is about
to be four years old
did she wander out at the the apartment
that night maybe going to show mommy and
daddy she was about before
look mommy and daddy I'm big enough to
come to your restaurant table which was
just sixty yards as the crow flies the
other side of swimming pool and Here I
am and did she try to do that well and
did she
that was the then an opportunist
abduction may be unlikely that happens
to bump into the one fella or woman in
the street who wants to steal a child
pretty unlikely but there is a
possibility the streets were riddled at
that time with deep trenches that they
were redoing the sewers of sewer and
water system for the town deep I mean
really deep trenches and I it is not a
stupid theory it is hypothesis to wonder
whether she fell into one of these
trenches and maybe got covered up by the
first scoop of the bulldozer in the
morning but the workmen who were
the trenches said they hadn't seen
anything like that so that that is one
possibility
second possibility was there was it
which Scotland Yard
consumed through quite a while was it a
burglary gone wrong there had been rash
of burglaries an awful lot of burglaries
which incidentally now that the people
staying at that beach resort had been
warned about but people breaking into
apartments to steal money to steal the
camera to the phone and how to had it
had a burglary gone wrong had the little
girl started to make a noise while the
burglar was there had something on
terribly wrong when he tried to silence
her well I conceivably there's no
evidence of it except that the were
burglaries and the work some men
suspected or being involved in those
burglars in those burglaries who whose
phones were near the apartment that
night checks eventually found and that
they were interviewed and were for a
while for suspects but there's no
evidence that happened there is however
a third possibility which we have leaned
towards we're not claiming to to know
anything that is special but we had
gathered all the information and there
is the information that makes us lean
towards the notion that she may have
been abducted deliberately in a planned
abduction from the flat avi there is
pretty good information from three or
four witnesses that the apartment was
watched in those days and on the day
itself abandoned disappearance man
seeming to noticeably be leaning on a
wall looking eyeballing apartment 5a on
different days and seen by the same
witness on on different days and then on
the very afternoon
of the disappearance when the McCanns of
the children were out playing tennis or
at the beach doing the things you do on
holiday a woman in an apartment above
the McCanns looked down and saw a man
who seemed to sort of emerge vertically
into the only way is in the afternoon
and then leaved by the little gate that
led to the main street seeming to check
the gate to see if it made a noise as if
to see if it made a noise did it squeak
or something like it looked like
somebody on a reconnaissance operation
whether it was or not is another matter
but it did look like that
there is also the matter of the charity
workers and that's robbing the bank is
described that well there were in that
period just around the time Madeleine
disappeared men going door-to-door in
the in the Ocean Club Resort and in the
apartment complexes nearby collecting
for what they claimed was an orphanage
in a nearby village well we went to the
nearby village and there wasn't and had
never been anything like an orphanage
there we contacted this you know the
state agency that operates such you know
such programs never was an orphanage
there so these men whatever they were
doing
it wasn't collecting for an orphanage
now perhaps they were casing for
burglaries later perhaps they were just
pulling off a small fraud collecting
bits and bits and bobs of change but
perhaps they were also doing something
else and one of the the most troubling
incidents we heard about and we were
told about was one in which charity
collector came to the door and while the
mother of the house was dealing with him
she noticed that the man seemed to be
talking to her but looking over her
shoulder at her three-year-old daughter
who was playing on the floor behind her
later that day she noticed the man
loitering about the following day while
she was upstairs doing the laundry she
started to come down the stairs
and as she did so she noticed that the
man was in her living room with her
three-year-old child now as soon as he
caught sight of the mother he scampered
away back out the door and gone and and
and she didn't catch up to him
but given that you know charity
collector three-year-old girl
it does sound troubling and those things
were not properly investigated at the
time and were being investigated by the
British police and their Portuguese
counterparts in this latter
investigation that has taken place since
2011 but the third possibility and the
thing that we've just described about
the charge of workers may be part of the
third possibility is and it's really
startling it's in denied three years
until Scotland Yard put it together and
made it public which is that in the
years before and just after Madeleine
disappeared there had been 28 28
episodes of an intruder coming getting
into flats and apartments usually with
British children within 40 miles of
prior to lose now that's a high rate of
intrusions but by any standards in in a
small place and the man would come in
usually appeared to be from the
descriptions of the children as far as
they could manage from being working in
the night was of a swarthy man with
stubble on his face talking English but
in evidently foreign accent with a sort
of funny smell about in which they the
children couldn't describe and in one
particularly chilling incident which we
found out about actually the man had
come in and got onto the bed with a
little girl whose sister was his room
and she'd said something like is that a
new daddy and and it was it wasn't daddy
man had had a medical mask over his face
I'd learned covering covering his mouth
most of his cheek and had cloth towels
or or table causal cloth around his feet
one think perhaps to make sure he didn't
need footprints on the bucket floor that
sort of thing and on that occasion that
it'll go with not as sexually assaulted
in any way but in other on other
occasions the little girls had been
sexually assaulted now the local
constabulary we described this before
there were two constructors in two
police forces in Portugal the Gardea
that available which is they the regular
policeman the guy who who drives the
patrol car around the guy who does
traffic duty and so on and the PJ the
policia judicial who do investigations
now clearly breaking into houses and
messing with with little girls is a job
for the the PJ the police edulis yes and
in almost all locations the lovers of
those other children said have said only
the local cops came and you know took
down a few details and then Avila when
there was no follow-up it is a shocking
revelation it can it plays into the the
theory coupled to the man watching the
man testing the gate and and the suspect
charity collectives it all plays into
the notion that she was deliberately
abducted that would also the fact that
the intruder was so prepared it would
appear with a mask over his face with
towels around his feet would play into
the fact that there was no prints that
were found at the crime scene of
Madeline's disappearance it might it
might indeed there was was there a
partial palm print there were a few
Marshall prints they were later
identified and police don't quote me on
this because there most of them were not
identifiable one of them belonged to
Kate McCann one of them belonged to one
of the police officers who was doing the
fingerprint work I put the UM again not
great disciplines in some cases in terms
of gathering the fingerprints yeah we
have one thing we haven't touched on and
again it's it's important evidence and
it's important in terms of people as
they're thinking about this case is that
there there were two sightings that
night that have been considered a
particular pool relevance which is that
at about 9:15 please forgive me I'm not
I don't have the paperwork in front of
me the McCanns
hot friend Jane Tanner was coming back
from the the tapas area where they were
having their their meal and as she was
approaching the intersection of the
street on which the McCanns apartment
was located she saw a man a man who
appeared to be dressed not like a
tourist but more and more sort of heavy
proper clothing than you normally saw
the tourists in a dark jacket in a kind
of mustard me or tani trousers with dark
hair slightly long at the back and this
man was carrying a child and he was
carrying the child like this you can't
really see in your podcast but with his
arms outstretched in the little child
laying across them in a kind of awkward
posture but the child seemed to be
deeply asleep and she was wearing
pajamas he or she was wearing pajamas
and the reason I use the word she is
because the pajama pants apparently had
a light pink or floral pattern much as
later was described by Kate McCann
pajamas of Madeline had been that night
now lots of little girls wear such
pajamas it's not a definitive thing by
any means that man was seen for years
one didn't know who he was
in 2013 the British investigators the
police came forward and said they
thought that they knew who the man was
at this point and that he had come
forward originally
and identified to himself and I did not
ever found its way into the record and
that he was a British tourist another
doctor in fact had been carrying his own
daughter home from the babysitting
service from the crash completely legit
there's only one oddity in that and
those of us who have looked at this case
closely have all registered it and
that's that the direction that the man
that Jane Tanner saw seemed to have been
traveling in the opposite direction of
the men that the man might or should
have been taking had he been doing that
now we can't explain that we cannot
explain that anomaly perhaps has been
satisfied satisfactory explaining to the
police I would note that the McCann
family's website where they keep a kind
of updated postings on this case they
remain that the the police artist sketch
of that man remains up and he is still
considered a perfect person of interest
so I think there may still be some small
doubt about that and then there's a
second incident a second incident at
about 10 o'clock that night described by
an Irish young man perhaps
Tony would like to describe that well
about 10 o'clock that night which is
precisely the moment that back a
department five a mrs. McCann conned her
child missing and another another man a
a man was seen carrying a child coming
down the steps that it is a sort of
Street of steps by a family of a blond
Irish family of a large a large family
and he the memory was that he didn't say
anything I believe they said good night
because it was late
good evening or what's that and he did
just didn't respond walk slowly deal now
he could have been another innocent
father bringing his child home Oh could
he could he maybe have been because this
has been
another sighting a relevant sighting of
an abductor taking madeline away but
there is no answers in fact of this much
confusion has been caused over it
because at one point the father in that
family that saw the child that child be
being carried later saw had seen Gerry
McCann Madeline's father arriving back
in Leicestershire off a plane and he
thought oh that looks like the guy we
saw that night but the rest of the
family didn't think this I think be the
father and the family thought it
possibly because of the way that he was
Gerry McCann was carrying one of his
other children at the time that he was
getting off the plane and somehow put
two and two together made about twenty
yeah yeah they explained it on his gate
didn't they they said that's the posture
posture and his posture just reminded
him on the earth and there are only so
many ways to carry most of the point in
in this episode is the fact that there
is multiple evidence that at that moment
at 10 o'clock Gerry McCann was first at
the tapas restaurant with with his
crowded friends having his dinner and
then rushing to help his wife and
searching searching commandments so the
man on the street with the steps and
what was the distance between the tapas
restaurant or apartment 5a and the
sighting by the Smith family we've
walked it's not five minutes it's but
it's very close right um you know yeah
I'm not sure but it wasn't so if the the
implication from Jane town he said was
nine fifteen so there's a father it
seems odd for it have to have been the
same man at scene Jerian life unless he
paused somewhere yeah because there's a
forty five minute gap
45-minute ish gap between one siding and
the other now you are relying on both
Jane Tanner and the Smiths being very
exact in their timings but they they are
pretty reasonable in their timings
because of Jane Tanner was timing things
sort of because of when she was doing
checks on children and the the Irish
family I think they think they were
timing it to the time of sort of closing
time the exact teacher but one do the
time more or less you you you go to an
important point that about the tiny
you're on holiday you're going out to
dinner there's no suggestion by the way
that anyone was rip-roaring drunk any of
the individuals involved but you're on
holiday it's getting dark it's late
props are closing and that didn't buzz
coffee leather clothes
it's the end of the day and you're all
on holiday you're not watching a watch
to see whether in the case of the
doctors that they got to go to another
patient they were relaxing on other date
you can't oh I don't know what I was
doing it precisely to approach this
afternoon and I'm sure you don't either
agreed so I want to listen yet no no
yeah in three hours time I work out
whether or not it is so I want you to
touch on on two things before we finish
up so firstly I wanted to ask what the
current status of the investigation is
the current stage of the investigation
is that every year for the last couple
of years
the Met has asked for a small charge of
money a hundred and fifty thousand
pounds to cover you know six months of
work or three months of work and they
have scaled back their team from about
thirty officers to only three or four
they have said repeatedly that they are
pursuing a line of inquiry that they
want to finish before they conclude
their investigation they
have a line of inquiry that they think
important enough to continue to want to
pursue the money always seems to run out
in March and in September and they have
just requested funding for a full year
now that's interesting it's interesting
to us and and this is it can only be
conjecture one would imagine they
wouldn't be doing that unless they
thought a that it was completed in that
amount of time or that they had
something that they thought was
important enough but perhaps a little
bit more complex than they originally
have forecast it would be that they
really needed to work on for that time
so so one wonders the continue the
investigation is continuing it remains
an open investigation in Portugal as
well but as of this moment we're in a
rather in a bit of a news vacuum how
about how love the the McCanns private
investigation is that obviously they
will still be doing things themselves
but why important and it can only be an
impression we have not been involved
with the McCanns personally
person-to-person for some time now that
of years but we we we we had the
impression that even then as soon as
Scotland Yard took over the case in
England and then the the Portuguese who
had shelved the case up to them got back
in to the investigation themselves
liaison amicably at that point with
Scotland Yard and that the McCanns who
had previously used private
investigators to dig all over the all
over Europe and further and beyond that
they ceased and left it to the police
which was only right you can't have cops
and private detectives all going at
things hammer and tongs at the same time
my impression is that they are waiting
being briefed by Scotland Yard when it
is relevant to brief them and trying to
get on with their lives a very difficult
task
because they are still pursued
venomously by the very internet trolls
so this social are still threatening
spreading poison about the supposed
involvement in the death of their
daughter
we just don't think we've had a moment
to stress it and if we are soon to
complete this conversation we should we
would like to stress that the fact that
in all the work we've done on this case
we never found an iota of an indication
that the McCanns had in any way being
guilty involved in their daughter's
disappearance
that was the points that I wanted to
finish on which is I think because of
the obsession I have a number of friends
who like to read crime drama NCIS and
and true crime detective things a lot of
podcasts Atlanta monster the Zodiac
killer all of these stories which are
some fiction some fact and then
somewhere between adaptations and all of
the rest of it there is a obsession at
the moment or a particular kind of
almost romanticizing of these cases in
the general public and I think very
quickly what people forget is that there
are real people on the other side of
this it's what we touched on in the
beginning that when the internet trolls
go at it with regards to authors like
yourselves they forget that it's not
just a title it's an actual person
behind it and one thing that kept on
coming to me throughout watching the
Netflix series was if as the evidence
would suggest the McCanns aren't
implicated in the disappearance of their
daughter if that is true the extra
degree of suffering that the McCanns
have been put through is almost
unfathomable unforgivable you said it
you said it incredibly well that that is
is absolutely true if you know the
evidence suggests that the McCanns are
are the victims of a crime or a terrible
tragedy and to see them daily
having brickbats thrown at them even
seeing that there are those who even
having seen the Netflix film which I
think comes out firmly they did enormous
amounts of research and it comes out
firmly showing the flawed investigation
that led to their the McCanns being
implicated there are still people who
are using that as an excuse to vilify
the McCanns and I I just think where is
your compassion there is you know one
thing we should say we've sort of lost
touch and in his condone conversation
with with Madeleine herself is Madeleine
has soaked alive could she be alive well
the answer is perhaps the best of the
Child Protection experts in the world
say one should never leave hope and
there is a significant figure the only
published statistics on this are in the
United States of children that have
disappeared the latest figures show 40
percent end up sadly that I found dead
all known to have died 56 percent
eventually turn on even after 10 15 20
years and so parents should never leave
her lose hope and I think the clear
indication is that the McCanns
have not and refused to lose hope it's a
very it's thinking about what the
McCanns go through I'm an empathetic
individual and for anyone else listening
out there who is as well it's painful to
watch the way that they go through this
situation and they're forced to do these
press interviews and and try and they're
getting scrutinized for the fact that
Gerry McCann and it his wife don't show
enough emotion
well what Jame to do Joe me to break
down crying on air or German you get the
message across which we think will
actually help our daughter should I be
overdramatic or should I try and be
productive and you know I asked for the
people who are listening to think how
would they have reacted like genuinely
genuinely how would you have reacted in
this situation what what would the your
capacity to hold your emotions have been
because I've worked on the front door of
nightclubs for over a decade and I see
when someone gets knocked back by a
doorman that they lose their [ __ ]
they're there their arms are in the air
and they're saying that their dad's our
solicitor and this is going to happen
and he think right this was not a nano
gram compared with the situation that
these people got through and how how
he's but there's no way to prepare for
this one point that I thought was very
very interesting which was done by the
Russian computer programmer that was
briefly implicated because he done
Robert Moretz website one thing he says
on the Netflix show is no one teaches
you how to behave in this situation and
he's referring to when he comes out of
the his apartment I think he gets into a
car and he drives away and essentially
what he says is at no point in your life
are you taught what is the optimal
strategy to do when this happens and you
extrapolate that forward to the higher
degree of scrutiny over a longer term
that the McCanns have been through and
you think well yet what what becomes
normal what is normal in that situation
absolutely there's no such thing as
normal when the child do you have the
precious child that you have come by
thanks to IVF as in the case of
Madeleine disappears off the face of the
earth just like that
nothing normal I couldn't agree more
guys I really appreciate your time for
coming on today am i right in thinking
that there is an updated version of your
book now available there is there is an
updated version of our book looking for
Madeleine
and if you would like to we can we can
sit I don't know what you use for your
publicity but we can send you a cover of
the book we don't we don't have the
physical book because because we're in
Ireland and publishers in England it was
only went on the streets at the moment
they the Netflix series came out that we
can send you a JPEG of it which
fantastic well to the listeners it very
grateful if you would use that's fine to
the listeners who want to as you know
the modern wisdom Amazon shopfront will
have this book in the show notes below
all you need to do is click through if
you do purchase from there you will be
supporting the show at no extra cost to
yourself and also you will be able to do
some further reading on what has been a
really and fascinating topic if you have
some friends who you know enjoyed the
documentary please share this episode
with them I'm sure that they would be
interested to find out some more
information about this and I'm right in
thinking that Anthony and Robin you're
about to go and begin work on another
book is that right yes you tell us what
should we be writing that we even I even
in my foolishness a long time ago did a
book that hasn't been torn to pieces but
I the hounds yet on the Kennedy
assassination we did a biography of
Richard Nixon we've named some of the
books we've done what should we be doing
next oh wow what was I like well the
Mueller reports just come out I'm a good
idea I think one or two other people
might be paying attention to I think a
couple of the book and and to a man
called Trump we have a thought of doing
a book of that nuclear nuclear warfare
new nuclear batters and because I find
that whereas my generation and people
younger than me were acutely aware of
the nuclear threat curing the coal
war and so on that now you talk to us
anybody under 40 really and true awful a
lot of people under 40 or younger and
say you're rushing there and they say
what didn't quite get that don't they
don't really don't know what he was and
mentioned Three Mile Island to them
which of course is not not a bomb but it
a disastrous leak of radiation from the
power plant and they say Three Mile
Island one that somebody said to me
creamer Three Mile Island well that must
be where they dropped another of those
bombs
I mean so we think that since the
nuclear threat is still real that maybe
we'll write about that so I will put in
the show notes below for anyone who
would care to listen to it but Sam
Harris recently did a podcast with
Professor Nick Bostrom from the future
of humanities Institute and this guy is
the world's expert on existential
threats essentially and the particular
discussion that he had was very
grounding I've listened to a lot of
Nick's work and some of the listeners
will have done as well
but I'll I'll send it to you guys once
we finish I highly recommend that
another interesting point for people who
listen to my episode with Jordan Hall
the owner and founder of neuro hacker
also the founder of the DivX codec from
20 years ago he is thinking about how to
redesign civilization as a whole from
game a to game be a game which is based
on conflicts - a game which is based on
collaboration and one of the things that
he brought up there when you're talking
about the the nuclear threat and
existential threats generally at the
behest of humans in the in the world is
that as technology advances previously
it would have taken huge resources to
cause a small amount of damage as time
progresses and technology progresses
unfortunately it swings to the other
side and as Nick Bostrom's famous
example is he says we didn't know what
it took to create an atomic bomb now it
could have taken putting son
in a microwave if all that it took to
create an atomic bomb is to put sand in
a microwave you would have this
emancipated delegated distributed
capacity for destruction on a huge scale
in the hands of people who have a
kitchen appliance now fortunately
because of the way that physics are put
together that's not the case but it
might not have been so it might have
been the case when the some of the first
atomic bombs were detonated in the
atmosphere they didn't know whether or
not it was going to literally ignite the
entire atmosphere and they were prepared
to do those tests take that chance
exactly so I think hey if you guys if
you go for nuclear endgame and and that
sort of stuff I'm we're gonna have you
back I would love I would love to
discuss that one as well although if it
takes 25 years we may be you know the
song that they play at the end of dr.
Strangelove we'll have to stop worrying
and not the bomb and we'll meet again
don't know where don't know when but I
know we'll meet again someday so maybe
we'll meet again when we do the nuclear
book that sounds fantastic guys I really
appreciate your time thank you so much
for coming on thank you Chris thank you
[Music]